well there's one other clip I wanted to
play from last night before we move on
and I wish I could play the whole
exchange but it's it's too long I have a
kind of a longer clip that I'm going to
play it still but you can find the whole
clip of my what my Twitter page it's a a
during the Q a a person who identifies
as trans
who's going through transition right now
did come up to speak in the Q a and this
is doesn't happen very often this is
pretty rare I mean I do these q and A's
and anyone can come speak and I'm always
encouraging people don't agree with me
to come speak and very rarely do they
take me up on it they'd rather go uh
stay outside where they have their
numbers and they can shout into
megaphones and hold their signs and all
of that this was someone who actually
came and spoke and stood up there and uh
and I appreciate that it takes courage
it takes guts to do that
um from from you know from from his
perspective this is like walking into
Lion's Den this is behind enemy's
territory from his we're not his enemies
but that's how he would see it and so it
takes guts to do this so I thought this
was an important conversation I wanted
to share
um
a piece of it with you here it is
eight months ago I was diagnosed with
gender dysphoria while I was impatient
here in UW-Madison
um
I looked into the research and like
talked to doctors and through my uh
journey I decided to explore medically
transitioning
you know because it's shown to decrease
suicidal ideation stuff like that
um
and since then although I've had to deal
with other issues such as transphobia
and sexual assault I've been more
happier overall than I ever was before
and my question to you is what
specifically about medically
transitioning do you think is so immoral
that we should ignore the potential
benefits and why should I listen to you
as somebody who's not a medical
professional and has not experienced
gender dysphoria there's a dishonesty
behind it dishonesty in the false
promises that they make
which is that you can attain this image
of
maleness or femaleness
but that you can actually become in some
ways the the opposite gender or sex
whatever word you want to use
which is a lie it's not true
you never can and I I have a horrible
Adam's Apple my my voice sounds like
this I still love myself and there is
only when you spend money in making
people happy like wearing nice clothes
or good food it does cost a lot of money
that's why I can't get surgeries that
would make me a lot happier
um
but the point of medicine is not
supposed to be to make you happy in the
moment that's not that's not the
objective of medicine the objective of
medicine is your overall wellness it's
about treating what is actually wrong
that's that's medicine and so if you are
struggling to
accept
who who you were born as what your
actual biological identity is I have all
the compassion in the world for that I
mean I can't imagine having that
disconnect in my head it has to be a
source of immense despair
but what I hate is the is the medical
professionals who instead of helping you
with that and how instead of helping you
to accept who you really are and find
joy and fulfillment in it
they're trying to make a quick buck and
they're selling you false promises and
they're telling you this stuff is based
on long-term studies and they're lying
to you because it's not there have never
been any reliable long-term studies on
almost all of this stuff because the
fact is the medical industry only
started doing this at such a large scale
recently so they couldn't have the data
they're pretending that they do they're
lying and that's what I hate
that's that's the immorality
[Applause]
okay so like I said that was a piece of
that's kind of the beginning and the end
and then there's the middle two which
you can find on my uh you can find on
YouTube where you find it on Twitter
um and I wanted to show that to you
because first of all again I just I
appreciate the fact that somebody was
actually willing to go and stand up
there and ask a question
um
and and also
I want to show that it's it's you know
we have this idea
that when you're talking to someone who
actually is trans or actually identifies
that way and is going through the whole
process that it's like we have to choose
between
being compassionate
or being truthful
those are two
separate paths those are two different
choices that's the way it's presented
that's not the case I think you can be
compassionate and also
um say what is true
which is what I tried to do there now if
I have one regret
and this is not meant as a criticism of
the audience who are great and really
all the audiences we've had on this
store have been have been awesome very
supportive and I appreciate them all
very much but I regret in some ways the
Applause for me at the end there not
that it was inappropriate it's just you
know it's the audience's way of saying
they agree and um and it was not it's
not like a combative Applause but it's
uh it's the nature of the Forum that's
how it works in that kind of form that's
fine but it does you know kind of makes
it sound maybe at the end like uh Matt
Walsh destroys type of video and that's
not what it is it's not what I intended
I certainly hope that the the student
you know didn't that that wasn't his
takeaway
um it's not this is not a matter of
trying to debunk or embarrass someone
certainly
um I care about him I do um I I care
about these kids who are being taken
advantage of
I know a lot of them
hate my guts they think that I'm a
horrible person I'm a monster and I get
that
that's how the way they see it that's
okay
but I care about them
that's
that's why I care about the issue
because people like that
who are
dealing with something dealing with
something real but it's internal it's
like something in his mind something
real
and if I had a chance to follow up with
that student I would tell them
first of all that you know it's it's
gonna be okay I know I know he's
suffering I don't doubt that
I know it
uh but it's going to be okay he is okay
there's nothing wrong with him
physically he says there that he uh he
talks about he hates his Adam's apple
and his voice but
there's nothing wrong with any of that
you know that's that's that's him that's
who he is
and there is nothing wrong with that at
all
that's who you are there's nothing wrong
with who you are
the the trouble is is when your mind is
not able to
reconcile with who you are or for
whatever reason is not wanting to accept
who you are
and so it's that struggle to accept that
that is the fundamental issue that we
need to try to address
as I'm always saying it is very much on
our side which is the side of uh of
Truth is very much a message of actual
self-acceptance
of real affirmation
well I hope you enjoyed that clip from
Matt Walsh show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or have listened to the full show
head to dailywire.com And subscribe
today you can also listen to my podcast
on Spotify Apple podcast or wherever you
get your podcasts